hi there today i didn't get much done
again i'm uh getting worried here uh i'm
in the back uh the back nine so to speak
the back half of my 90 day challenge day
51 i believe it is out of 90 days
um you know we have um i had business
meetings all day we have a
uh software system for sawmills and for
the wood industry our chief it guy
resides in toronto he was here we were
visiting with
uh potential uh users here in vancouver
then we had a dinner with him and the
staff
so even though i've got this first uh
episode of my kim jung-ha
uh podcast transcribed i've done maybe
three or four paragraphs there and going
through you know uh linking the words
saving the words so that i can then read
it on my ipad
while listening to it
didn't get much done but tomorrow i'm
going to devote more time to it i've
also spent a fair amount of time
uh again because this whole ukrainian
ukrainian situation is so interesting
there's a tremendous war information war
going on now with
all kinds of information flying around
and you don't know what's true and what
isn't
i listen to vladimir putin's press
conference
where he stated categorically that the
troops in the in the crimean who seized
uh you know therefore airport or
whatever that those are not russian
troops and there was an interview at the
muskie with a ukrainian
um officer who
said he interacted with those people and
they were from the
from the um russian black sea fleet
that's there of course the russians have
every right to station up to 25 000
troops
in their
naval port there according to the
agreement
but of course they don't have permission
to charge around the crimean countryside
with uniforms with no insignia
seizing various strategic assets
so we'll see what the truth is there
according to this ukrainian officer the
uh people who were going around with uh
unmarked uniforms were from the uh
russian black sea fleet
and some uh former uh berkut
uh security forces from the ukraine
who knows i don't know now there's a
report uh
of a leaked conversation between the
estonian foreign minister and the eu
foreign minister that suggests that the
snipers
at the maidan square were actually
members of the opposition not
uh under instructions from yanukovych to
fire on people but that's based on one
witness who was subsequently this is a
nurse and then that nurse in another
article i read was interviewed and
claims that this was not the case that
she never said that so there is a lot of
information flying around so really all
we can do is sit back and wait
uh and hope though i mean it was
encouraging in
prime minister putin's uh
interview that he says that if
the due process is followed that that
there are parliamentary elections and
and so forth and that there's a
government that is actually elected by
the people which is not the case with
the government right now
um
even uh yatsenyuk and these are not
people who have been elected by the
people to represent them but if there is
a legitimate government in the ukraine
he's going to work with them he already
has contact with even some of those
existing people there
and so i have the feeling that things
will gradually
wind down
although there will be some fallout and
i guess time will tell and as part of
that i have lined up some conversations
not have only do i have conversations
lined up with two korean tutors here at
link i'm also going to be talking to one
ukrainian
one russian and one
tutor from belarus
so i will be getting some different
perspectives on this whole situation of
course what most of all matters is that
um life in the ukraine gets back or in
ukraine gets back to normal as quickly
as possible it is rather sad to see that
the
if you look at the statistics the
economic performance of ukraine has been
so poor that their average standard of
living now is significant significantly
lower than in russia and significantly
lower than in poland even though poland
20 years ago was equivalent to the
ukraine now poland is three times where
it was the ukraine has actually seen
their standard of living decline so out
of all of this
we hope that the situation improves for
the ukrainians and i can't see how their
situation situation can improve without
the significant significant involvement
in a positive way
of russia and russians